Allah
know we mentions in his book
in the chapter regarding repentance
a narration on the authority of Musdam
said indeed Allah most high does extend
his hand in the night so that the
wrongdoer of the day may repent and he
does extend his hand in the day in order
that the wrongdoer of the night may
repent
and this will continue until the sun
rises from its place of setting meaning
from the west. This narration has been
collected by imam Muslim. A similar
meaning.
The next narration on the authority of
Muslim.
He then mentions a narration on the
authority of Abdman
who mentions that the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii wasallam says
said
whoever repents before the sun rises
from its setting rises from the west
Allah will accept his repentance and
forgive him. This has been collected by
Imam Muslim.
[Silence]
He then mentions a narration on the
authority of Abdman.
Of course, we mentioned previously that
people are known by different things
with regards to their names and titles.
Sometimes people are better known by
their kuna Abu. Sometimes people
are better known by their first name
Abdullah meaning Ibn Masoud.
Sometimes people are better known by
their father and being attributed to
their father Ib Omar and Ib Abbas.
This narration is on the authority of
Iben Omar. Anytime you see in the books
of hadith that the companion's name is
Abdullah just that it's Ibn Mash.
And anytime you see in the books of
hadith
ibar or ib Abbass, it is always Abdullah
Abdullahbar Abdullahb Abbass because
Abbass has brothers. He has siblings for
instanceb Abbass and he has narrations
also or he had instances and
interactions with the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. Iban Omar has
siblings as well. However, these are the
these companions are very very well
known by this title to the point that it
wouldn't mean anyone else in this
instance.
And these three companions,
they're often referred to as the
Abdullahbnb,
Abdullahbn Omar, Abdullahb Abbass,
Abdullahbn.
They have narrated a huge portion of
narrations of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. They are of the most prolific
companions in narrating.
Iban Omar narrates that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said
indeed Allah
the mighty and majestic
does accept the repentance of a slave as
long as he is not in the thrashes of
death. In the thrashes of death. This
wording
is referring to a phenomenon which is
known in the medical world as a death
rattle. And that is that when the
soul is being extracted from the body
and a person is taking his last breaths,
there will be a rattling in his throat.
Right? Some of us have maybe heard that
firsthand. Others maybe have heard of
it. This is referred to as a
it's called a death rattle in English
because this is the
final thrashes of the physical body in
death. This is when the soul is being
extracted from the body. When a person
hears this, the person who's dying can
see the angel of death. Can see the
angels of death. And at that moment,
everybody repents. But there's nothing
special about that repentance. Even
repented. Even Abu Jah, everyone repents
when they're in those thrashes of death.
When the angel of death is extracting
his soul. Therefore, when this happens,
that is the moment the point of no
return. That is the threshold that once
it is crossed, person's repentance will
not be accepted. Anything before that is
accepted by Allah provided the
conditions that were affioned are
present.
Alhamdulillah.